so this is yonshin and sorry i'm not
there in person i will try to be there
in person soon
so let me start with a quick
introduction i'm a assistant professor
in aerospace engineering in georgia tech
so before that i was a student at the
university of minnesota so this was me
where i was a this is me when i was a
happy student
i have quite a broad research interest
so
this is basically a
diagram i like to use to summarize my
research interest so basically we do
research in the intersection of control
optimization and machine learning and
the
two tools we use very often are optimal
transport and stochastic calculus
so uh because this is like a talk to
introduce myself to the samus community
of berkeley community i think
i decided to
really go over my recent work instead of
focusing on welfare so that's what i'm
going to do quickly very quickly so the
first one is about the graphical optimal
transport
so this i don't think i need to mention
this anymore this is just a standard
discrete optional transfer problem
and the
one of the most popular reason to solve
this is the sinkhole iteration which
looks like this the graphical orbital
transport is most related to the
mathematical orbital transport problem
so this is the mathematical optimal
transport problem and this other
constraint and this is the cost and this
is the definition of the projection
okay so this problem uh has appeared in
many applications and the one problem of
this is that
the computational cost is really high
and it's largely because that
the optimization variable b
is a j dimensional tensor and due to
this if you don't explore structure
there's no way you can
be fast because it always have a
exponential dependence on the number of
modulus
so
of course you can always do the single
iterations on these algorithms and the
algorithm actually is really
simple but the problem is here when you
need in each of this iteration you need
to do this projection and this is
extremely expensive if you don't explore
the structure
and luckily
in many uh
marginal optimal transport problem the
cost tensor actually has a structure and
the structure we are interested in is
the graphical structure is basically
when the cost can be decomposed
according to a graph a very standard
example is the washington valley center
the fixed support one so you can
decompose your cost as a pairwise
summation between the transport cost
between your
very center and each of the marginals
okay
and it turns out for this type of
problem and this is what we mean by
graphical optimum transfer it turns out
for this type of problem we can combine
sinkhole
and
some brief propagation or junction tree
algorithm which is widely used in graph
models to do the projection step in the
previous
in this algorithm then combine these two
uh we can get some very efficient
algorithms and the complexity of this
type of work with scales like this and
the w here is the keywords so if you
have a tree the graph is a tree then the
dependence on the d is actually just e
to the power two and it has only linear
dependence on the number of marginals
which is pretty good
and uh
of course there are many other
structures one can explore to study mot
but uh here we would just uh consider
the graphical structures
uh that's because uh the way we started
this problem these are the two examples
i'm going to skip because the
the reason we started studying this
problem is actually due to
this washington spline problem so it is
well known the displacement
interpolation optimal transport has a
really nice property it's like a it's
like some type of linear interpolation
for distributions so these are the
distributions
so our question was that if
we have a sequence of distributions
instead of two how do we interpolate
if you do the displacement interpolation
you will get this piecewise linear
like integration that is not what we
want and because we want this to have
some type of extrapolation property so
that's why we introduced this rajasthan
supply it turns out later that
this can be viewed as a special case of
the graphic optimal transport just with
this very specific graphical structure
and
the next one is a
aggregate inference problem is a very
interesting problem in
filtering and estimation
it basically
gives you one approach to
estimate the group behavior from a group
measurement
so i'm going to skip the detail but it
turns out this is a graphical transport
problem again so this is the first part
the second problem i want to
uh mention is this shooting a bridge
problem uh of
which imagine unbalanced marginals so
the shooting the bridge problem you can
view showing the bridge problem as a
entropy regularized optimal transport
but the shooting a bridge problem had
actually a very uh
nice
physical meaning so the original problem
was studied by schrodinger what he was
interested in is that
if you have like a 1000 particle here
they start from sound distribution
then let's assume they follow some
dynamics now you should be able to
predict the terminal distribution i mean
because you can just follow the heat
equation or the focal planck equation
but let's assume when you make a
measurement this is different from that
prediction how do you infer the most
likely trajectories around this
so the problem we consider here is that
assume let's say you have one million
particle at the very beginning but they
only have like half a million particles
at the very end some of the particles
get absorbed and this is uh this means
the particles may get killed during the
process this happens very often so the
problem we consider is if you have these
two measurements how do you infer the
most likely trajectory including that
what's the most likely way some of the
particles get killed
so
it turns out for this problem so if the
if the underlying dynamics of the
trajectories underline dynamics of the
particles follows this diffusion with
this killing rate
then
this can be the solution can be capital
characterized by this uh schrodinger uh
system so this is a
is like extension of the standard
sharing the bridge theory
and the next one is a
it's like a is a density control problem
uh so when we study the control of
swamps swan robotics so the swamps they
actually interact with each other
example a specific way so here we assume
we have enlarger and
our goal is to find out a control
strategy to minimize the minimum to
minimize the control energy okay but in
the meantime you want the robot that's
one to go from one configuration
to another configuration it turns out
that in the mean field limit
and when the n is really large this
problem can be formulated as this
problem and uh if you are familiar with
the sharing of bridge you see this is
very similar to assuring the bridge
problem so these are the marginal
constraint the only difference is that
the prior q
depends on your solution so this is what
they call the mean fear the schrodinger
bridge problem it's a very interesting
problem and this problem um
is
is more complicated than the standard
schrodinger bridge problem because first
of all is another convex problem
so
our work along this line is basically
developing algorithm to do that so
basically we use some milo proximal
gradient algorithm and it turns out that
we can combine this with a single and
some other
algorithms to solve this so this is just
to show you what would happen to this
type of things so this is the initial
distribution and this is the terminal
distribution and here we are trying to
interpret these two distributions so
this is optimal transport solution the
one on the left but if you assume
they have some the positive potential
then it turns out
with some specific parameter this is the
solution so i can you can see
you can see the actually the repulsive
interaction between them
so
and uh
this is the
this actually is what i propose to do
during my stay in salmon
so this is the uh in this
work what we want is to minimize the
uh
is to do an infinite dimensional optimal
infinite dimensional optimization
problem so the optimization variable is
the proper probability
density
okay
so this is what we want to do so we
consider a specific class of problem
where this function can be written in
this variation of form so there are many
examples like this the standard
expectation and or the sampling problem
which is the clear divergence for both
of them you can read write this in terms
of some variation of form okay so assume
you can solve this get the maximizer
then it turns out the gradient the
washestone gradient
for this the gradient flow direction can
be written in this way so basically if
you have the optimizer then the gradient
flow is just the gradient of this and
based on this observation we propose
this variational transport algorithm
which basically
instead of solve the original problem we
solve this saddle point problem so each
iteration we try to solve the in the
maximization loop to the end then once
you have this optimizer you try to push
the particles uh using this optimizer
you following the washtank region the
descent
so uh
here uh in this algorithm uh the
distribution mu is modeled by particles
so you don't need to discretize the
space
okay i think that's the
that's what i want to say about my okay
oh sorry um just one more thing because
i saw uh hold on discuss normalizing
flow i think it i just added this slide
could be interesting to some of you so
here this is a new algorithm for
normalizing flow we call this diffusion
normalizing flow so in normalizing flow
normally you have this deterministic
process so you don't have this diffusion
you only have this and the forward
process from data to gaussian or
backward process from gaussian to data
they are the same they are just the
inverse of each other so in this
algorithm diffusion normalizing flow
we use two
uh two process to model them so this is
the diagram to show you the difference
and
the way we reach handle is to really
just minimize the uh the
distribution of these two process on the
trajectory space
and when this g converged to zero this
whole thing would reduce to the standard
normalizing flow and this is just some
low dimensional performance comparison
so the second one is algorithm and the
third one is the diffusion model and the
last one is the standard normalizing
flow and the first one is the first law
is the
data
okay so
just quickly i want to mention some
earlier work we did when i was a student
and the first one is covariance control
uh
we consider the problem really from
engineering perspective so for instance
this is a setting we are interested in
suppose you have a let's say spacex
rocket you want this to land at some
specific regions so you see here you
only have this much area so you can land
on
so in this problem what we want is we
want the state of dynamic systems to
start from the initial distribution and
then you want to achieve some target
distribution and we assume cautionarity
for simplicity and it turns out that
if
if the underlying dynamics is linear
then this can be viewed as a
generalization
of the optimal transport problem or the
schrodinger bridge problems and it has
closed from solution and the other
a lot of research we
did is this uh
what do we call the quantum optimal
transport or matrix optimal transport
so in most optimal transport
problems the object you study is the
distribution is a distribution in
euclidean space anyways distribution but
in some applications
you have
for instance in quantum mechanics you
don't have proper probability
distribution you have something called a
density matrix right is a trace one
matrix positive definite and inside
applications for instance signal
processing
the power spectrum of a multivariate
signal is actually a is a matrix value
uh
matrix value distribution because at
every frequency
a matrix a positive definite matrix
would capture the energy distribution of
your signal
and
also in the
diffusion tensor image in mri
and the eti is a very specific data set
that they would use in this data set
very interestingly at very every
pixel
you not only have a
number to tell you the intensity of this
you also have actually an ellipsoid so
this gives you a little bit more
structure so to us this is the matrix
the value distribution and we develop
some tools to study this type of problem
okay i think that's at the end so my
goal in science is really to explore the
geometry of distribution and to study
this
relation to sampling and optimization
and they hear some takeaway
and
some reference
okay that's that's all thanks
okay so uh we're uh running uh very much
out of time so uh uh use the time i
encourage you to uh direct questions to
uh
and so we're going to move on to our
last speaker
fiona sperman